hey guys welcome back to City skylines
by the looks of it this is going to be
the second to last video of this series
and it's kind of a filler video in that
it doesn't really have any sort of
central thing that I'm working on I'll
be doing some highway stuff mostly a
caravan park and also little water
treatment plants among some other random
stuff that I really need to get in in
this peninsula here and also some farms
which I still got almost half the
footage of making the farms but there is
just so much of that and it's more or
less most of this part of the series
just because I wanted to finish this
general area to make it look somewhat
realistic and coherent but though I did
want to cut some of that out because it
just gets really repetitive anyway over
here I wanted to make a quick don't dog
bone interchange just to get a
connection to that little sort of
regional highway that I had going over
here and it's also going to be the main
sort of entry to the theme park which is
going to be added just around this area
in the upper left side of the screen at
the moment which I'll get to in the next
episode but I basically wanted to have a
dog bone interchange here because it's
not that rare of a thing to see in the
Netherlands actually and it's just much
better than a dumbell interchange which
is kind of a dumb interchange anyway
because it has two roundabouts on both
sides but though it seems like a more
logical shape than the awkward dog bone
shape they're kind of like one part of
the roundabouts in a dumbell is kind of
useless because you can only use it to
make u-turns and a dog bone interchange
is just more efficient in that sense and
in general it's just a really useful and
efficient interchange anyway and I
figured because you see them quite often
in the Netherlands as well it would be
really nice to use in here since that
road is probably going to have quite a
bit of traffic coming in to get to the
town which is on the other side of that
pretty long regional highway there I
also wanted to extend the highway over
here a little bit and at this bridge
over here just to get an intersection in
at this place as well because the plan
was at the time though I highly doubt
if I'll ever get back to it just because
what my current plans with city scanners
are but yeah my plan was to get a quick
intersection over here to get a road
leading into the like lower part of the
screen at the moment and maybe work on a
harbor because I still had some room
left there but at the moment I think
that's just too much effort to really
get into and while I definitely want to
finish this map in general to a somewhat
presentable state I think there are just
too many sort of loose ends to tie up to
make it worth not stunning over and do
something else which I would rather do
and it's just a bit easier to finish the
general area and make it look like it's
part of a somewhat realistic touch area
instead of really going with all the
original ideas that I had so this is
going to be kind of an awkward
intersection that is not actually going
to lead anywhere but just the middle of
nowhere and what is probably going to be
just grasslands in the end but yeah that
was just the idea behind this sort of
section it's quite inspired actually by
the idea of the a-15 around Rotterdam
which is like a highway that goes by the
harbor and it's really close along the
rivers and the dikes and everything like
that
so I took some inspiration from that to
see if I could get like a harbor with a
real MA highway alongside it but that is
not going to happen
most likely anymore and around here I
just wanted to have a couple of
floodplains as well like with the idea
that this one river is really one of
those rivers with quite wide flood
plains around it rather than just dykes
all around these sites directly so I
really wanted to follow that on all the
sides of the river as well and maybe add
a few more lakes in if I still have some
room for that left too and here I just
wanted to make sure that this awkward
little empty area which has been empty
for the longest amount of time is
actually finally filled up with a bit of
very simple farmland nothing too
interesting I was thinking about maybe
getting some forests in here and there
though I do already have a forest around
that sort of Delta
area next to the river and maybe this
area would have been quite nice for that
but figured hmm I would rather just get
a couple of extra farms in here and get
it over with a little bit more quickly
than putting trees all around this area
and yeah truth be told I think it's just
most relevant for me to talk about the
future of City skylines for me rather
than what I'm doing in this map since
it's all sort of cut in stone already
and it's not the most interesting stuff
aside from maybe just the caravan park
because that's something I actually
haven't seen before and something I just
really wanted to try but um yeah my
future plans still are to not really
continue this series beyond what I have
at the moment just because I think there
are just other things that and this is
the most important reason for me
personally will be just more fun for me
to make and I sort of I'm not tired of
the Dutch style I would actually love to
try it again at some point in the future
I just think like I said before the city
doesn't really work out anymore and it's
outdated for many different reasons and
I'd rather just start over and try some
other projects and keep the scale a
little bit more on the reasonable side
because truth be told the original scale
that I wanted to go for with the city to
try and fill all the 81 tiles in
hindsight was just well ridiculously
ambitious and something that I don't
think I'll ever be able to make and at
the moment I still have like these sort
of three main things that I kind of want
to try like a skiing town though I may
actually do it in the summer just
because I think it is a little bit more
interesting with the foliage and all
that and it's not possible to get a
actual functional skiing town in any way
and I think it would actually be
interesting to take a sort of summer
look into the ski resort idea it's also
something that I haven't seen before
and the second idea being that I kind of
really want to make a planned city like
Doha get some inspiration from likely
planned parts of Dubai and other
economic cities things like that Korea
actually has some really interesting
planned cities going on to really go
into the very smart city and economic
city
kind of ideas and another third sort of
plan that I still want to keep in the
back of my head is maybe try a new touch
City with all the new parts all the new
molds and assets and really amazing
stuff that has come out ever since I
started this city that more or less make
this city look kind of outdated by now
so yeah those are still my plans and I
still kind of want to do either one of
those three I'm still not entirely sure
which one but yeah instead of continuing
this series but I do still really want
to play City skylines just as a well to
quickly mention that any way to get into
the caravan park parts of the video and
this is something that I had to look up
a lot of stuff on the internet about and
I'm still not entirely sure because like
I've been calling this a caravan park
you might also call it a holiday park or
stuff along the lines of that I'm not
entirely sure how to exactly refer to it
because there are just many different
like connotations and meanings of these
different words throughout the world and
like the sorts of parks are might
probably be kind of different and have
sort of different customs in different
countries so I'm gonna go buy the really
Dutch idea of this and split this little
park into two sections this section is
going to be like a real campsites kind
of area so it's just going to be for
caravans pretty much use empty fields of
grass for people who tour by with a
caravan to just have a temporary stay
and like park their Caravan in here and
just leave it at that so this is kind of
like the temporary sort of parts of the
well the camping grounds or something
like that whatever I should really refer
to it as and this will also we have like
just a couple of benches and other
little parts of it on the left I
actually did also want to have like a
middle section which I'll return to but
the other like second half of this part
is going to be like a more holiday park
ish idea with mobile homes which are
just gonna stay there forever for people
to buy or hire them or
yeah something like that and they're
just pretty much gonna stay there all
the time and they're more or less laid
out in a more vacation home kind of idea
maybe a bit similar to Center Park
something like that so yeah the main
idea is really that the one half on the
right is really the temporary sort of
close to nature
camping idea and on the left it's more
like the vacation homes with the mobile
homes and things like that and in the
middle section I just wanted to have
like a quick simple sort of public area
with a restaurants and the main building
of this entire little park and of course
just an area where people can sit
outside some toilets a playground and a
little football field because how can
you really live without a football field
in the Netherlands and yeah that's
basically how its build up and within
this section of the little mobile homes
I did want to have like one section
which is completely ripped off actually
from the place where my grandparents
actually have one of these little mobile
homes which is like very grid like and
has all of these little plots and on the
left side it's much more like a vacation
sort of holiday Park and more scattered
around with these little stone pots and
decorations and a bit more room and it's
a bit less sort of organized so there is
still kind of a slight difference that I
did want to play around with a little
bit so yeah that is basically what this
entire little park is gonna be all about
I guess the only thing that's missing
realistically is something that's more
or less worth visiting like this is
quite inspired actually by the camping
grounds that you see scattered around
the Dutch coast what's actually quite
interesting is that the Dutch coast is
rather protected like there aren't
hotels and boulevards alongside the
entire thing it's mostly just dunes and
forests and just clean beaches because I
think there are really strict
regulations on building hotels and
resorts alongside the Dutch coast to
keep it clean and so what you do find
here and there is like these simple like
camping grounds which are close to the
coast but not entirely right next to
them
for people to just stay in the general
area which is pretty interesting and
this is sort of like the idea that I
took it from though I do have to say
there isn't really any sea nearby in
this case so I have no idea what these
people would actually go here for but
then again there is also like a little
holiday park near my town and there is
absolutely nothing to do in my town
whatsoever
so I guess I can just have a little one
of these caravan parks in the middle of
nowhere in the Netherlands because it
seems like a thing that actually there
are many of these caravan parks
scattered throughout the Netherlands
regardless of how dead the area is for
some reason and it still boggles my mind
that people are actually into that stuff
and when I really go into the middle of
nowhere where nothing is really well
where there's nothing to do anyway but
yeah that's not kind of my thing to talk
about over here I also needed to really
get in some extra forms around here
which was more or less necessary though
I still skipped quite a bit of that
since it's just quite boring and
repetitive actually one of those things
which I would love to get back into city
skylines because there is like a recent
mod with which you can at which which
you have some custom brushes so you
don't have to use the resources to get
different sorts of textures onto the
ground which is just one of those things
which makes me really want to start a
new city and like get up to dates and
actually start a city which doesn't look
like it's from five years earlier of
cities skylines the pretty core of this
or whatever anyway I also wanted to have
a quick sewage treatment plant over here
which was kind of stupid like I actually
looked up some videos on how a sewage
treatment plants work and things like
that and and found all sorts of articles
and things and I eventually just ended
up realizing that this is just such a
small town and barely anyone lives
around this area that realistically I
should just have a really really small
very simple treatment plant over here so
it's not going to be anything
spectacular just sort of keeping up with
the scale of the town and the mostly
farmlands area
it's actually also quite similar to the
treatment plant which is near my town
but yeah so it's quite a simple thing
over here I definitely still needed to
get a treatment plant nearly like main
city of this map but quite awkwardly I
really didn't find the time to do that
and actually I happen to also look up
stuff just to make that treatment plant
only to realize that I don't actually
know where I would actually place that
thing yet and I still have no clue where
it could possibly fit if not alongside
the harbor's that I was planning but I
probably will never get into so it's
just one of those things which will
probably be lost forever and also one of
those things which I really hope having
more time in the summer vacation will
help making it more easy to actually get
into everything that I want to do
without hitting time constraint and
stuff like that anyway that is right
about it for this video because I still
have like many many more minutes of just
making farms and stuff like that but I
don't elongate it much more than I
really should that's a weird word I've
no idea why I said it so yeah I'm gonna
call it a day here and I'm sorry about
this sort of little random video of the
series and the fact that I didn't really
have much to show though in the next
episode I'll work on the theme park
which is actually one of my favorite
things of the entire city so at least a
good way to hopefully end the series and
pretty much finish the city off and yeah
I hope to see you guys in the next
episode